[Musik]
das vierzigste kosovo kontingent wird in
der klagenfurter khevenhüller kaserne
verabschiedet rund 400 soldatinnen und
soldaten werden in den nächsten sechs
monaten ihren dienst in den
verschiedensten funktionen versehen
[Musik]
bei einer abschließenden einsatzübung
wird der schutz von liegenschaften vor
angreifern noch einmal ging die annahme
für unsere übung ist dass es zu
spannungszustände im einsatzland selbst
gekommen ist damit wir unsere soldaten
richtig ausbilden können haben wir ein
erhöhtes bedrohungspotenzial angenommen
es ist mit demonstrationen zu rechnen
mit anschlägen und mit gewalttätigen
ausschreitungen gegenüber den soldaten
selbst
[Musik]
ich möchte mich herzlich bedanken
nochmal bei jenen die hier diese
ausbildung sicherstellen und vor allen
dingen auch jetzt hier diese überprüfung
machen nämlich jener soldaten
das konnte gegen sk vor 40 der in den
nächsten tagen dann in den einsatzraum
verlegen es ist notwendig und wichtig
dass wir unsere soldaten bestmöglich
vorbereiten auf alle möglichen einsatz
szenarien
das ist heute hier auch eindrucksvoll
bewiesen worden und zeigt auch auf dass
wir beruhigen gewissen nämlich ich also
politische verantwortung als
verantwortungsträger auch die
kommandanten der verantwortung tragen
unsere soldaten in den einsatzraum
entsenden können und auch dort wieder
wie gewohnt großartige leistungen
treffen
die tore
federführend für die ausbildung und
aufstellung des vierzigsten kontingents
für den kosovo einsatz ist die siebte
jägerbrigade die mehrheit der rund 400
einsatzkräfte stellt das jägerbataillon
[Musik]